this is just the best you might recall
how could you have forgotten already
that in mid-december democrat doug jones
and pat maybe you want to just double
check on that you can i'll keep talking
you just double check what's going on
there
Democrat doug jones defeated serial
accused child sex offender roy more in
an alabama special senate election to
replace jeff sessions who left his seat
to become attorney general for donald
trump this was a completely unique
situation a hugely unpopular president
in trump is why the seat is vacant in
the first place since trump did after
all select jeff sessions to be attorney
general and normally a republican would
easily win a special election in alabama
but in the republican primary the
accused serial child sex offender won so
then you had a democrat want winning the
election because the republican
candidate was just an absolute and total
disaster and of course all along if
instead of special elections to fill
senate vacancies alabama simply had the
governor appoint an interim senator none
of this would have happened
and that's exactly what alabama is going
to do going forward this is just so
funny the Alabama House of
Representatives has changed the rules
the law we're going forward there will
not be any more special elections in
these situations and instead the
governor is going to appoint someone who
can serve up to two years until the
state has its next regularly scheduled
elections since more than likely Alabama
is going to keep having Republican
governors for a while this is a good way
to prevent the disaster for Republicans
that was last year's special election
Democrats were opposed to this rule
change not surprisingly Republicans
passed it basically along party lines 67
to 31 since there are way more
Republicans than Democrats in the
Alabama House and Republicans of course
are saying oh this has nothing to do
with keeping Republicans its power in
power it's because these special
elections are expensive and were fiscal
conservatives and that special election
cost about 10 million dollars Democrats
aren't convinced they seem to get what's
going on Congressman John Rogers who's a
Democrat from
ham he called it the anti Doug Jones
bill I actually don't think this is a
terrible idea
I mean lot lots of states do this
instead of having a special election
when you have an unexpected vacancy an
intra term vacancy the governor appoints
someone and then at the next regularly
scheduled state election you just have
an election and then you decide who's
going to be in that seat but the doing
of this weeks after Doug Jones a
Democrat won a special election in
Alabama it can't possibly just be a
coincidence it's obviously a reaction to
that yeah I think it's okay though I
remember in 2013 Chris Christie made a
special election in New Jersey yes and
it seat sure because he just didn't want
to be on the same ballot as Cory Booker
cuz he knew that that would hurt him
sure it cost the taxpayers they're like
over 20 million dollars absolutely
stunning how much it costs and I
understand I'm not writing off the
fiscal conservatism argument I'm just
saying if they were concerned about that
they could have changed this rule long
before a Republican lost right because
special elections have existed for a
very long time did he see that once it
was clear that Roy Moore would have a
difficult time winning the election that
the Governor of Alabama KIV was thinking
about pushing it off and talking with
the White House that is interesting not
surprising at all though what happened
so what we had like someone trying to
break down oh we got a package oh we got
a packet yeah it was that urgent that
they needed to continually bang I
pretended to be you I signed the name
and everything okay something
interesting coming in and open it is it
is it a large package or small a pretty
big package a large package oh it's a
interesting I think it's probably
envelopes was it heavier light it was it
was light yeah yeah how did you big
black is like yeah it's envelopes it's
uh it's it's bubble mailers okay I
ordered and anyway very exciting day as
you can tell it david pakman show
studios discuss this or any other story
including deliveries during the show on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t next I will talk to write
Bart's see Edmond right we did not get
along well last time he was on the show
let's see what happens this time today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by brilliant which is a
great online
service that allows you to master
interesting concepts in math science and
engineering by solving fun and
challenging problems and unlike other
learning sites when I'm using brilliant
I'm learning by working hands-on with
real-world scenarios and problems you
solve challenging puzzles that have been
carefully designed by expert educators
and professionals from all over the
world they don't go too fast they don't
go too slowly they take you step-by-step
through the topics you're interested in
at your own pace and one of their
principles of learning is effective
learning is active YouTube videos on
these topics are passive and it's great
to watch them and I do it myself but
that will only take you so far and
that's where brilliant comes in where
you learn not by watching but by doing
and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash david pakman the first 200 people
who visit brilliant org slash David
Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership check it out today
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman